Musique légère
...
Propos indistincts
-Ah bon ?
...
-Vous allez bien ?
-Oui, ça va.
-Bonjour !
-Bonjour.
-Comment il va ?
-Oh, comme un retraité.
-Il semblerait qu'il y ait
des attaques de loups
envers certains troupeaux.
A vérifier.
Je n'en sais rien.
-Oui !
...
La musique diminue.
-Bonjour.
Pierre Morel-A-L'Huissier.
Je suis depuis longtemps
député du département de la Lozère
et j'ai dans ce département
une problématique
qui est
la prédation du loup.
J'ai donc aujourd'hui
un combat à mener
pour protéger la filière élevage
dans ce département.
-Nous voici en Lozère,
une terre rurale, sauvage,
en plein coeur
des montagnes,
des lacs et des forêts.
A l'écart des métropoles,
76 000 habitants vivent ici.
Le département
est le moins peuplé de France,
classé au patrimoine mondial
de l'Unesco
pour son pastoralisme,
ses élevages
en pleine nature.
Aujourd'hui,
troupeaux et agriculteurs
doivent cohabiter
avec le loup,
réapparu dans les années 90.
Musique de tension
Le voici surpris
par un automobiliste.
La vidéo a été filmée
un matin du mois d'octobre
sur les routes
du département.
Les routes de Lozère,
justement,
Pierre Morel-A-L'Huissier,
député Libertés et territoires,
les connaît
comme sa poche.
Elu depuis 20 ans,
il est le seul député
du département.
Chaque mois,
il parcourt
plus de 6000 kilomètres.
-On quitte le nord Lozère
pour aller plutôt
dans le centre de la Lozère,
dans la commune de Fontans,
une commune très agricole.
...
-Rendez-vous est pris
dans la région de la Margeride.
Pays du Gévaudan,
le loup,
loin d'être une légende,
est devenu la bête noire
des éleveurs.
...
En Lozère,
266 animaux ont été tués
par le loup
l'année dernière,
contre 70 seulement
il y a 3 ans.
...
-Hé, bonjour, la maison.
-Chez Rémi, l'élevage de brebis
est une histoire de famille.
Il y a 6 ans, il a repris
la ferme de son père.
Le 8 novembre dernier,
l'éleveur subit
l'une des plus grosses attaques
du département.
-Bon, l'idée,
c'était de vous rencontrer,
rencontrer des agriculteurs
qui sont très intégrés
sur le territoire
et qui ne font pas
de l'anti-loup,
mais qui sont confrontés
à la problématique du loup.
-Nous, ça a commencé
cette année.
Jusqu'à maintenant,
on était préservés.
On a commencé
à prendre peur pendant l'été,
car tous nos voisins
y sont passés.
Du coup, un beau matin,
en me levant,
j'ai eu un coup
de téléphone d'Adeline
pour me dire
qu'on a été attaqués.
-Les brebis,
ça ne se sépare pas.
S'il n'y a que 10 brebis,
c'est que les autres sont...
Il y a un problème, quoi.
J'ai vite fait le tour.
J'ai appelé Rémi à 7 h,
en lui disant :
"Il y a au moins
4 mortes."
Ce que je ne savais pas,
c'est qu'il n'y en avait pas 4,
mais 11.
J'en voyais 4,
mais il y en avait partout
sur la parcelle, égorgées...
Mais toutes égorgées,
vraiment.
Dans celles qui restaient,
il y en avait...
-Il y en avait
14 de blessés.
Sur les 14,
on en a euthanasié 11.
-Sur un troupeau global de...
-Il y en avait 80.
-80.
-Les 58 brebis rescapées
sont aujourd'hui rentrées
dans l'enclos
et ne ressortiront
qu'au printemps prochain.
Une trêve pour les animaux,
mais aussi pour l'éleveur,
encore marqué
par l'attaque.
-Voilà des photos des...
Et carrément
devant les maisons.
Un peu plus,
il était dans le jardin.
-Putain...
Aïe, aïe, aïe, aïe, aïe...
Ouais. Ah, ouais...
-Rémi recevra de l'Etat
5000 euros d'indemnisation,
une compensation économique
qu'il juge
insuffisante,
sans parler
du préjudice moral
et du traumatisme subi
par ses animaux.
-Les rescapées du lot
qui s'est fait attaquer.
Et les blessés,
on les a soignés
et on a eu de la chance,
c'est bien revenu.
-Reconnaissons
que le loup a
une évolution exponentielle
sur les territoires,
et régulons.
Je ne vois pas quelle autre
solution on peut trouver.
On a même des naissances
de louveteaux dans un département.
Ca prouve bien qu'ils s'installent
et installés, on fait quoi ?
-Selon un dernier comptage,
près de 1000 loups seraient
sur le territoire français.
Pourtant, au début du 20e siècle,
l'animal est au bord
de l'extinction dans le monde.
En France,
une quarantaine de loups
réapparaissent dans les années 90
à partir des Alpes italiennes.
L'animal est alors classé
"espèce strictement protégée"
aux niveaux national,
européen et international.
Musique réflexive
...
-Allez, on va... on va commencer
cette assemblée générale.
Air de guitare doux
-Ce matin-là, le député
est venu soutenir
une filière locale
reconnue pour sa production
de viande de grande qualité.
-Salut.
-Tu as signé, déjà ?
-Non.
-12 500 agneaux élevés
par une centaine d'agriculteurs
qui a obtenu
le label IGP,
Indication géographique protégée,
notamment pour son pastoralisme.
La filière se porte bien, mais voit
planer depuis plusieurs années
une ombre,
celle du loup.
-On sait que la cohabitation
qu'on veut nous est impossible,
surréaliste.
On n'est pas anti-loup.
C'est juste
pas possible. Faire cohabiter
prédateur et proie, ça n'existe pas.
-Qu'il y ait des pro-loup,
des anti-loup, j'en ai que faire.
J'ai un équilibre économique
en Lozère,
un socle de 15 %
de la population active
dans l'agriculture.
J'ai une filière d'élevage
de qualité.
On le retrouve
sur plusieurs massifs.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait
pour ces éleveurs
qui entretiennent le territoire
et font vivre notre espace ?
-Dans l'assemblée,
1 éleveur sur 5
a subi une attaque
l'année dernière.
Pour les accompagner,
l'Etat a mis en place
une série de mesures,
toutes jugées inadaptées
par les éleveurs.
La discussion tourne ce matin
autour du patou, ce chien
dressé pour protéger le troupeau,
parfois agressif
sur les randonneurs.
-On a le chemin de Saint-Jacques
qui traverse l'exploitation,
entre notre bâtiment
et notre maison.
Mettre des patous,
ce n'est pas possible.
-Le loup est passé,
il a vu les patous.
Il s'est décalé
chez le voisin.
Le voisin a pas de patous.
Il a attaqué.
Ca décale le problème.
-C'est du boulot.
Je suis en train de les éduquer.
On aménage la bergerie
pour l'éduquer au mieux.
Le patou, c'est des dégâts aussi
sur les agneaux
parce qu'il joue avec eux.
C'est du travail.
-Les éleveurs qui sont rentrés
dans ce système, que je ne juge pas,
passent finalement autant de temps
à s'occuper de cette problématique
que de faire leur vrai métier
de paysan.
-Et s'il y a un accident,
la responsabilité pénale,
c'est l'éleveur,
le propriétaire du patou.
-L'ancien avocat
écoute et conseille.
Mais Pierre Morel-A-L'Huissier
le sait,
en tant que parlementaire
français, il n'a pas
toutes les cartes en main.
-Vous appelez au déclassement
d'une espèce
strictement protégée
aux niveaux national, européen
et également international
avec la Convention de Berne.
Un déclassement ne peut être
la solution à court terme,
car il est peu vraisemblable.
Il faudrait que l'espèce
soit parfaitement restaurée
et que la décision de déclassement
soit prise à l'unanimité des pays.
-Modifier la convention de Berne
pour retirer aux loups
le plus haut degré
de protection et ainsi,
assouplir les règles
en matière de régulation.
La France n'y est clairement
pas favorable,
tout comme les défenseurs
de l'animal.
-Là, vous êtes vraiment
sur un biotope idéal
pour le loup
puisque vous avez sur les mamelons
des forêts.
Le loup va pouvoir sortir
de la lisière
et examiner
ce qu'il peut manger
à son menu du jour.
Il mange comme nous,
à la carte.
Nous, c'est le restaurant,
Lui, le territoire.
-Nous rencontrons Manoël Atman,
sans le député
qui n'a pas pu
se rendre disponible.
Naturaliste dans l'âme,
cet amoureux du loup
s'imprègne de son environnement
pour mieux l'analyser.
-Les loups,
ils connaissent pas
le découpage préfectoral
des départements de Napoléon.
Les meutes sont à cheval
sur la Haute-Loire, la Lozère,
d'autres sur la Lozère
et l'Aveyron, etc.
Je pense qu'il y en a quatre
qui circulent, au minimum.
Musique curieuse
-Pour lui, une cohabitation
avec le loup est possible
à condition que l'homme s'adapte
à l'animal, et non l'inverse.
...
-Ca, c'est des traces de chien.
Elle est assez ovale,
avec une forme de coeur.
Ca laisse penser au loup,
mais c'en est pas.
Bien qu'elle corresponde vraiment
à une forme géométrique
assez proche du loup,
ce qui la trahit par rapport
au loup, c'est la largeur.
Les éleveurs
qui se protègent du loup
ne veulent rien
apprendre de lui.
C'est dommage,
ils sont vraiment dans un rapport
de rejet total.
Ils gagneraient
à collaborer avec des naturalistes,
même favorables aux loups.
Un exemple concret :
on n'a jamais testé
les filets horizontaux au sol
dans lesquels les doigts du loup
se prendraient
et cela gênerait sa progression,
le troublerait.
...
-Mais plus que de troubler le loup,
le député veut
une mesure plus radicale :
être autorisé à abattre
un plus grand nombre
de loups chaque année
et pour cela,
donner plus de pouvoir à son préfet,
celui qui autorise les tirs.
Aujourd'hui, en France,
174 loups peuvent
être tués chaque année.
Un quota fixé par l'Etat
dans le but d'éviter
la chasse illégale,
punie de trois ans de prison
et de 150 000 euros d'amende.
-On ne peut plus aujourd'hui
mettre en place
ce qui se mettait
en place auparavant,
au risque d'accidents graves,
c'est-à-dire des pièges à loup
et des empoisonnements.
Il faut trouver des techniques
et pour ça,
comme n'importe quel sportif
qui veut réussir une compétition,
il faut s'entraîner.
Il faut que nous nous entraînions
pour aboutir
à la mise en oeuvre complète
du plan national d'action,
pour que nous sachions éliminer
les loups qui créent
trop de dommages.
-Sur le terrain,
c'est à la Louveterie,
une institution
créée par Charlemagne,
que revient la mission
de réguler la bête.
Avec le temps,
le savoir-faire
de ces chasseurs bénévoles
s'est perdu.
Et aujourd'hui,
ils demandent plus
d'occasions de tirer.
-On va passer l'année
à passer la nuit dehors
pour voir une queue de loup
passer entre deux arbres.
On travaille suivant les lois.
Ce cadre, vous le faites.
Ce cadre-là,
il doit évoluer pour...
Ils parlent en même temps.
-Le problème, c'est qu'on est
dans un cadre très contraint.
La loi nationale
n'a pas la maîtrise
ni de la convention de Berne,
ni de la directive communautaire.
Donc c'est un gros travail
qu'il faut faire.
Mais ça touche
des législations
qui sont au-delà
de la législation française
donc c'est compliqué.
-On est démunis,
on a le loup là,
mais on ne sait pas...
Il a de l'avance,
il a de l'avance sur nous.
Il a pris de l'avance.
-Pierre Morel-A-L'Huissier
ne compte pas
en rester là.
Avec une trentaine
d'autres parlementaires,
ils envisagent de saisir
le Conseil d'Etat
et de porter plainte
contre le gouvernement
pour non-assistance
à personne en danger.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA